- A leak of a draft opinion shows
that the Supreme Court is going
to formally overturn Roe v. Wade
and Planned Parenthood v. Casey.
It is written by Justice Alito
joined by justices Thomas,
Gorsuch, Kavanaugh, and Barrett.
It appears to be legitimate
and there are no denials
from the Supreme Court.
Now, this draft may change.
It's from February 10th.
There will be some negotiating
from the other justices
who will have some notes.
Notably, Justice Roberts does not appear
to join in the decision.
And while Roe and Casey
have been effectively dead
for months, this opinion would formally
and explicitly overturn those cases,
largely on the basis that the rights
granted by Roe and Casey are not, quote,
"deeply rooted in the past jurisprudence
of American and British law."
So for a SCOTUS opinion, this
is stark and in your face.
There are absolutely no punches pulled.
But it remains to be seen
what the final version will look like.